Welcome to AV testing podcast your modern testing podcast your host Alan out here and Brent
Will be here to guide you through topics on testing leadership agile and anything else that comes to mind now on with this
Hey everyone, it is spy and
Brent is still off working on Satya the boat this week. Got to scrub some barnacles off the bottom
So I am here with Lena Zubait. Lena say hello. Hi everyone
Very nice to be here
Lena has been on the podcast before I wanted to give her a platform to talk about some things that have been on her mind
You know, just a fantastic person. It's been like probably at least a year probably more since we last talked, right? Yeah, I think so
What have you been up to?
So many things but so so
It's really hard chance for these kind of questions right when quite a lot of time has passed because a lot has happened
But then what are you supposed to say? Well, what are you doing these days these days?
Writing a book actually talking about professional
Yeah, every time I think I'm almost done I find things that I'm nowhere close I do need more routine and discipline because
I think I'm not writing that much but I am worrying about it
So then I have this guilt surrounding me that I'm not writing
So I'm just spending my energy thinking about it instead of writing
So I will tell you a little bit. I want mainly that you talked today
But I talked a little bit on the last podcast with global warming
I've had a modern testing book and a business fable narrative fiction in my head for a long time
And when I was hiking this summer, I thought through it a lot got a lot of thoughts in my head and in about six weeks
After I got back kind of started maybe in the September
Somewhere in there. Anyway, it's I keep my finding typos
Oh, I want to address this plot hole blah blah blah, but it's getting it's getting towards done
so I've been working on that for a while and
In that case, I just had so much of it in my head
I just had to dump the outline out and the way I write same way
I wrote how we test software at Microsoft or even the chapters I've done for some of the other books is I write a
Very iterative style. I write an outline or something that looks like an outline. I go through it
I iterate over it hundreds of times running a little bit more every time until
It's kind of like forming a statue out of clay. This is my stuff
I think some people write probably the good good writers like write quite a bit differently
But that's what worked for me. So I kind of had a lot of it in my head
So I spit out bits
I wrote the beginning first and then the end and then I filled out the long middle
and then I kept lots of notes on on
Meeting which meeting rooms I'd used and stories like that. But anyway, that's my story. What's your book about? My book is
going to be about bug bashes and
Because I never yeah
I've done multiple bug bashes. It's quite to tell you quite a
Fascinating experience I would say because there's always a surge of energy after a bug bash and everyone is inspired and I was like
Okay, let's put it to a book. So that's how I started gathering ideas about it
I also think I've learned on the way about structure and how much work it is structure
Actually, so it's not just that you write this brain dump and then you're done
Of course you could write you could release just that but there were so many lessons on the way even like this
Just in time versus just in case that I as an expert
I really want to like say everything and I want to say just in case you were thinking about that
I would like to add that but that can overwhelm the reader
Because you should more right with this just in time mindset
So it was super helpful for me and the structure overall as well or clutter
As my editor says there's these sometimes like throat cleansings like words and sounds
like it's one of them or like
Like that's what we do in speech
but there are also sentences in the writing that sound like that and then it's like how do we
Actually make it as few words as possible, but then still have that meaning
it's it's almost like that quote like I would have written a shorter letter, but I did not have time and
So I wrote you a longer one. Yeah, and that's that's exactly the case for me with this book
It's such a journey because it's not just me writing out the the mind flow
But it's mostly thinking about structure editing what makes sense. Where should I say which part?
And that's the biggest journey. There's this book on writing. It's one of the classics about writing. It's so good
You have it. I also have it somewhere. I have it. It's in a box of it
Yeah, but but it I don't know. It's so so many learnings in this process
But I'm super grateful and I hope I see the end of the tunnel and actually release it
Yeah, I forget which one is which but I got into a kick many years ago. I really wanted to
Understand more about the writing process whether I was gonna be any good at it or not
And so I read I think the on writing that the Stephen King one
No, he wrote a book about writing. That was pretty good. There's on writing which I've read which is a different one
There's one called bird by bird
Rather than actually work on right
Doing it and hopefully some of it will sink in but I do the same thing with leadership books
I just read a lot and hopefully some things, you know stick and I try them and they work
What I found is I
Haven't written. This is my first time ever writing long-form fiction
I've written, you know short stories a long long time ago
But after I got done I said, okay, I finished the story and I went looked at it and I
It was very repetitive without me even realizing it like that the protagonist as the
Enters the room and and and has the same reaction every time so I had to go and fix all that
It was like oh, this is hard
Yeah
So and yeah, it's a it's a process. So that's exciting. I'm glad you're working on that. So
Yeah, let's talk about you that we're here because you
Sent me a note over LinkedIn and said basically I'm gonna paraphrase so spy I have a
Headful of things I want to talk about and and I need a platform
I said this is a platform for you always I said before you're always welcome on the AB testing podcast
So let's get started and I guarantee I will have opinions on all of these topics
because
There's a it was great is the note had some things to talk about
But not there's always a story on the reason why and I love it and I have some strong opinions about this first topic
which is
Something I have harped on for years and I still see
this particular part of
I'll call it project management software delivery companies. I'll call it companies abused and misused all over the place
Let's talk about metrics
So I'm gonna just stop there and talk about like what is on your mind with metrics these days that made you bring it
Up in a note to me. I don't know that is a topic that I keep
Coming back to I think years ago when I worked in ThoughtWorks
I remember making this slide deck for to for the client right to explain that there are different metrics
There's team metrics. There's empowerment metrics and there's delivery metrics. And what do we want to measure here?
What kind of project this is and there are so many dimensions there and
Once I made this I thought that will be it
But then years passed and I kept coming back to the same
slide deck because people would just take out certain metric and say oh, yeah, that is the one that you measure everything and
And I do think there's so many of them and I find this conversation
Fascinating because I think a lot of teams do not know what success is for them
And it's such a like easy question, but also a very hard question because sure you can say
Oh, yeah, like a number of something but you can play this. It's not really your kind of success metric
But also I think most of teams don't really have anything
Which also is almost like going blindly and like what are you supposed to do if you don't even know what you're tracking or
Like what are you visualizing? So I find metrics useful powerful
But very frequently abused and misused
Yeah, and I have a couple rants. Yes, go ahead. The first is that people tend to measure
what's easy to measure whether it and
Whether it tells them anything or not what we're looking for our signals signals that tell us something is going
Well are not going well
A lot of metrics just count a thing and we don't know what we're gonna what are we gonna do if this number goes up?
what are we gonna do if this number goes down and
people don't know they
Don't know I'll ask I'll ask John down the hall. Maybe he knows
so
One little rant is I bring this up. I brought this up a couple times recently. Actually my latest blog post
I brought it up when accelerate came out the the book on from the DevOps research
Whatever Dora stands for people got all excited about the four key metrics
Oh, we these are things that indicate whether we're elite quality
So we're going to measure release philosophy mean time to recovery and blah blah blah
Completely and I swear 95% of the teams using those metrics never read the book
because those metrics in the book were collected via surveys not via dashboards and
what we think I'm gonna kick off for you to to to bounce around is
Those metrics are the output of the system if you are doing elite engineering
If you are a really good engineering team
You will have more frequent leases releases. You will recover quickly more quickly, etc, etc
People track those as if getting to that number would make them good at software engineering and good at delivery
What they got good at was gaming the metrics. So I think
People are in constant search of how do I build and it's not just metrics and I'm gonna let you talk
But it's not just the metrics and random metrics and things they can measure that may tell them something
Then they want to build a dashboard
I think the dashboard is going to be that the tell-all that lets them know if the business is failing or succeeding so
We can go a little meta here. I'm gonna stop and let you talk about it
Why do you think people choose? Why do you think people mess up metrics? So often like what's going on there?
I say behavior comes from motivation. Why do you why do you think they do this stuff? I just think that yeah, I mean
Dashboard and like it gives you maybe a sense of achievement that hey we did it we are this right?
It's like it's it's a pat on the back. What? Yeah, we're great
The dashboard is all green and it's wonderful all tests passed, right?
You know those tests make no sense. And if you have no tests everything passes
That's another right meme that we have
I
Do think though that metric that dashboards can be useful
But there is a part here if they give you an actionable exactly
However, there is this part that is challenging which is people because they tend to game the system, right?
So they will play those metrics
And I think people also want some kind of silver bullet
They want someone to tell them what you measure and what you do
So if you say okay for key metrics accelerate great, we'll do it will be the best team ever
but why and how they are lacking this basic kind of principle for me metrics, I think is more like a
Conversation within the team that maybe would be dynamic and changing based on the team's goals as well as what they are
Trying to achieve and it's more not about playing the system but more about
Helping to see some kind of direction of the team. So I don't see dashboards necessarily as evil
Well, I I don't either
Unless that dashboard becomes well, here's why I think they're I'll tell you why I think they're evil why they can be
the dashboards
and again
To repeat myself and a contract from about to say a little bit
I think the metrics are an output of the system
You have an engineering system that delivers or doesn't or delivers with quality or doesn't or delivers with velocity or predictability or doesn't yeah
In the end though, it doesn't matter here's the thing maybe missing from
Accelerate people lose track of a lot of these metrics are about tracking
The system only do we have a good engineering system? Are we able to deliver?
Consistently with quality, but they don't track whether we're doing the right things for our customers. So
Yes, we need to measure both but we need to understand there's a difference between
Metrics that track how the delivery system is working and how customers are interacting with the software
They're there. It's different. Yeah, like customers don't do any of your customers care what your test pass rate is
Do they care what code coverage you had?
Do they care how many hours you spent on exploratory testing? Do they care?
They don't they want to know if that the software is valuable for them. Yeah, so
What do you do to track like what do you suggest? What do you think? How do you find that balance between?
metrics that tell you whether you're doing the right stuff on the software team and whether you'd and
Also knowing whether you're getting the right signals from whether you're doing the right thing for your customer in a sense
That's like a big
Metrics conversation because there's so many so there's of course key four key metrics
That's more like what engineering delivery metrics as you say right systems and the metrics
Those are I guess sort of useless for the customer, right? What am I going to do with that?
So what that you can you know recover fast?
However, this
Bigger chunk of metrics also could be sort of you could say product metrics. What is important for us?
What's the North Star as they call it, right?
So every company can sort of define it the way they do and they could be customer facing as well, right?
So for example, we deliver this many packages for the first time customers or something like that
I
Couldn't now tell examples likely because it needs like a specific product
Also another type of metrics
I think that we don't talk about frequently is even the team health or empowerment metrics
Oh, for example, there's
Tell I've done it for you talk. Yeah, so
in that
Slide egg that I did years ago. I also speak about different types of metrics. For example, there is code pipes article
so there's this blog, I don't know if you know about it and but
They tell that there are certain metrics like for example percentage of developers writing tests
ideal value and I would go for a hundred but actual value usually is like 20% and then it's also
about writing deterministic tests are like
Bugs being covered by certain things right and these are sort of empowerment metrics, right?
That we could easily also measure within the team, but then it's also a conversation with leadership
For me when I join the teams usually I'm a little bit annoying in a sense that I always say
Okay tech leads tech leads tech leads once I work with this CTO who was like, you know, stop talking about tech leads
I don't have your thought works tech leads
I have just these tech leads and I'm like they need training because I see this quality so
Depending on those tech leads and on good tech leadership overall because it's so much more than okay
I just sit and I just something and then I report a bug
No
like you should track even the growth of people the skills mattresses and so on that there is maybe this one developer who is an
Knowledge Island, right and nobody else knows about this part of the system. They go on holiday the all the development stops, right?
So what's the point of all those other kind of metrics while they are there? It's good
But then when they go on holiday, it's a different story. So there's
Delivery metrics the system metrics
There's product metrics that you could say the customer facing metrics right that what can be measured when it comes to customers
Maybe the website has certain tracing right that we can actually collect certain metrics. We can see the traffic
We can see how they behave right we can have a beta beta testing and other programs
But there's also this big chunk which I think is empowerment or overall team metrics
For me that that area is really interesting like learning of the team and growing
That it's not just these heroes right or these very senior developers, but it's also
People growing insurals right pairing certain practices like that if we go like very extreme programming
principles way
There's so many companies that are not doing that like even
You fix a bug at the test such a basic
Principle and I joined this one project and I said it somewhere and there's there was this developer that walked over to me
And said so why this senior developer who was always reviewing my code never told me this
And I was like, well now I'm telling you this you should add a test for you at the bug you fix
So but these are such basics. It's 101, right?
Yes, and it drives me crazy
I want to build. Yeah, I think now I went a bit on a rant as well
This is good because now I'm right. I'm riled up
One I talked earlier about the people who never read accelerate but jump on the metrics
I can tell this because if you actually read the book accelerate
Yes, the four key metrics are in there. You will also see research showing that or stating that
When developers own test automation, it's highly correlated with product quality
No such correlation exists if if a separate team writes those tests so right there that says well
If we want to be a good team
Don't yes, the metrics are fine
You can look at the metrics if you want get the developers to write all their own automation and it's it's written right there
But they ignore that part because tracking the metrics making a dashboard is more fun
the other point I want to build on and I worked at a company recently where
They didn't care a lot about software development and they didn't care a lot about people
and the research shows that and this is a
Really documented well and patrick lanchione is only work of nonfiction the advantage
there's a high high correlation between team health and
All of the instances are true across software all other industries team health and the product they deliver this can be pizza
And the pizza joint and people understand why their job is important if they're getting feedback and and and they're growing and learning
They will make better pizza and have better customer experience same thing for software teams
So many leaders want to focus on the outputs only are we delivering are we late? If not, you're in trouble
I'm gonna yell at you. There's no growth. I saw a post on LinkedIn recently someone was I
Thought it was satire at first till I looked at the comments and they're getting beat up some something to the
Come on LinkedIn too much looking at jobs
Something to the effect of I have a junior engineer came in and he expects to learn new things in the first eight months
No, I just want you to do your work. It's like
You're a loser and you have to build a learning culture
You have to build a culture where people feel like their job is important where
they understand
how what they do affects the company and and know if they have a path to grow and
They should always acknowledge work. You should always be learning
Anyway drives me crazy that companies don't care about this stuff and those things and the team health reports or are I
would dashboard those probably before I do Dora metrics because I know the team that's healthy is going to deliver and as
Context changes we're going to in my net, you know, those metrics will rise. Those are an output of the system
The people the culture are the inputs of the system. Yeah
Actually, I
Remember seeing that Etsy. I think you should have this
Little how was your day today like a few buttons and you could press when you're going out of the office
And I really like that idea because then like it's almost like in the airport, right?
You're passing through security and you see how your experience was
Like a little health meter for people to say if they had a good day or not if they like their job or not
I think is nice
But the challenge here is always and I think
now
Also being in this sort of quality role, which is the fluffiest thing ever
I realize that that's what I'm mostly working on and it's very frequently
Intangible because I cannot say oh, yeah
I wrote this many lines of code and then I fixed that many things implemented that many features
But it's mostly people but that's essential as well
It's working with understanding the systematic problems
I got into systems thinking because I realized that there's so many reasons right behind certain
Thing that manifests in the system and first we could say oh, yeah
Let's just you know slap some more tests on and then we will be fine
But then why did this happen at the first place?
And then when you start digging deeper you find these problems that a lot of people in the company may not want to admit
Even because they're hard people problems are much harder than oh, yeah
Like let's just you know fix this code for example
And but they are also way more costly and affecting the quality
And you don't get the immediate impact. I I fully a million percent agree
As Weinberg says eventually, it's always a people problem paraphrase
But that's why i've i've been in leadership roles so much because i'm really fascinated with the people issue with
like uh
I say, um behavior comes from motivation. So someone
makes a poor decision or
Or i'll only say poor because at the time people make unless people someone's being uh, purposely malicious
People make a decision because they feel safe with that decision given the given the information they have at the time
So someone made a decision that turned out to be wrong
So we can we can go into education on why that was not about blame
I love mistake because they're an opportunity for learning
And I want people to feel free to try new things and to grow
and I
Yeah, I I really am fascinated with the debugging of human behavior like oh
You know that that person was a little short or a little mean to that person during that meeting
Let me go give them feedback right away and find out why not not for blame
I can just go to
I'll pick on fred fred's one of my canonical dumb names
Um apologies fred if you're listening, I just a name i'm picking. Uh, I can say hey fred
Uh in that last meeting situation
You were a little short in your response to lena the the uh, the behavior
What was going on? I'm not going to lean in i'm not going to pass judgment. I'm not going to
uh say anything else I want him to
to just acknowledge it because
oh actually when I think back on it, yeah, I was thinking about some other problem I had or
Um, I have a or could be they have a problem with you
I don't know what it is, but I want to give fred a chance to talk about it
I say, okay
What should we do about that because that's
It's not a good way for us to work together and fred can go work on that
So I want people to get that feedback
I want people to make mistakes even if they make them inadvertently like that because it's an opportunity for learning
And I like it from the human side, you know, I I spent most of my younger years debugging
kernel failures and windows all day long
And uh, I like and I like it more it's more difficult debugging kernel driver issues of race conditions
That's easy compared to the people problem
So I really enjoy debugging people these days and understanding why they do what they do whether it's
Being meaner to meeting or whether it's choosing a poor set of metrics. Yeah
Exactly
I think there was this statement that you said right the people have to feel safe to do the what what
What they will do in the system depends on how safe they feel
And I think that's so essential and how do we actually increase this feeling of safety for people and frequently?
Yeah, we all want to do a good job
Yet in a certain company we may be the worst of us, right? We may not be the the best version of ourselves
Yeah, and how do we improve the system so that as many people as possible could
Thrive there even and bring the authentic self right with all the and not like the grumpy
Like this annoyed frustrated person who would snap at someone
Um, how do you how do you not become one though?
If you for example are surrounded by many grumps or like this like culture
Because that's I think one of my challenges as well in leadership roles because it becomes lonely and then you're like
I'm so tired being a grown up here
So it's interesting you bring that up
As you've heard on the podcast and by the way for those of you that are confused I hiked the pacific crest trail last summer
In the desert someone said told me I observed things
I noticed things and I also talked into my phone once in a while asked if I was a spy
And so that stuck as a trail name for me
Somewhere in northern, California
I became a new version of spy
I was thinking through a bunch of job stuff a bunch of life stuff. I became zen spy
and zen spy just
Doesn't give a shit
Honestly, it's those things i'm going to be it means i'm zen spy means I am going to be myself no matter what so
What that means?
Professionally is that i'm being very selective of my job search. I'm not going i'm going to go to a company
That cares about good software engineering
And they care about people and they understand this is the important part based on our discussion here. They understand that
doesn't matter if you have the
The top students of every university of research and engineering the best engineers in the world
quality delivery
predictability
those things are a result of
The system the system is culture culture and some rules and heuristics
uh
I
Believe and and there's probably some sports metaphor. I don't know if no about sports to find it
I think
With the right coaching and the right leadership and the right culture
any team of
engineers any team of people
Can create the most amazing products that people love it isn't about being knowing how to write a compression algorithm
I forget the one from from
silicon valley
outside in compression
whatever it's about the people
and
So I was in a job that didn't care about people and it frustrated me my blood pressure went up
My blood pressure is now
After the hike and after his ending out is like lowest has been since my 20s
So i'm feeling really good and healthy
Uh, and I want to keep that so what that means how you do that answer your question
Uh, the book I always recommend by the way, it's on my desk called orbiting orbiting the giant hairball
Which is a from an artist one to work at hallmark. I had to learn to live in bureaucracy
But
I am going to have zero tolerance
for
uh
Working an organization that don't care about people and I will weed this out 90 percent
To or more
In my selection for where I work next
and we don't always we don't all have this privilege to take our time finding a job where it's perfect, but
uh
Aline brent and I have used a lot of the podcast that you can change your manager or you can change your leadership
Or you can change your leadership
Meaning of course you can
Try and change and then help them build the culture which i've been fairly successful at in um
In many organizations not all of them
Or you can leave leave jobs
I am
I feel pretty confident that
In the next several months it may take one to six or more. I will find a role where I can
Uh
Have a large influence on the culture and also impact the cultures around me so we don't get into those
those places where people just don't care I
truly believe that
quality and predictability
And all the good things we want are an output of the system and the system is the culture
And again as I said before along with some principles and heuristics for delivery. You can't just be nice to everyone
That's that's not a good culture
That's um, what kim kim scott calls ruin this empathy sure I could be nice if we never deliver doesn't matter
So that's my very long answer of saying
One it's very difficult
to do that
Two it doesn't mean we shouldn't try. Yep
and
Uh, it is difficult to change culture. It's like culture is like the one thing that needs to be top down
Yeah, exactly like nothing, you know, like delivery cycles
Um, uh
And when I worked in germany, there was the statement that the fish rots from its head. I don't know. Is that also?
Yes
Yeah, that translates well the fish does rot from its head
And it doesn't mean that the leader has to say this is our culture. These are our values
Here's what I want to do. Although it's great when they do that, but they need to be supported
What are the signs or signals you're looking for? So for example, if i'm I I definitely
Realized that I need
A strong lead myself or like a partner in crime
That leadership level has to be on board with this
And if they're not or if I would need like to sort of convince them or something like in a way that I think
There's like too big of a gap
Then i'm like, maybe it's not a match for me that I want someone also that you know, I could work with
What are you looking for? Is it also leadership level that you're or what are the signals that it may be a good place for you?
That's a good question. Uh
Couple things one is uh, and I and what I will do this time my job search
I won't I didn't do last time if I will seek out folks on linkedin work at the company and kind of kind of get
I want to get the not the hand wavy
Like everything I wanted was promised where I worked last. It just wasn't delivered
So do the does the company do the company have values that make sense?
Yeah, and maybe not just the green washing and the values more importantly
Do those values come up in conversation are are they
Are they actually how decisions are made or are they just things written on a website that nobody does exactly?
Then you have then with that. That's the basis of a culture. How do I build around those?
How do I take the principles that I like to work with or heuristics?
Can I work those into if the company cares about the values and they come up people actually want to live by those
Kanda and just like metrics values can be abused, but I want to I can work around those at least
I want to understand how those values are being used
I'll start with leadership and get their hand wavy answer
But I can get a little bit from just human behavior, but i'll do some poking around on the team as well. I'll ask
I'll find out
Do I have a do I have a chance at working within a framework?
I need something to stand on if everybody does whatever they want and there's finger pointing and blame
It's one if it's my job is to fix that I will go do that
But if it that's from other parts of the organization, it's more difficult for me to fix that if it's not top down. Yeah
so
And I hate it because so many people want
Things to be solved by an executive mandate
And I don't need the executives or someone above me to mandate a culture because culture has come through cultures
Do not occur through a bureaucracy. You can't say this is the culture
And have it happen
You want support like this is the way we want to work. We want to have transparency
We want to have psychological safety. We want to have accountability
Which are the big things I care about so yeah, I I can help build those across
a
An entire company if you want those things those are they're not I won't say they're easy
but
They work together and they can help build the culture. So
I don't know there's an answer in there somewhere. I think it's difficult and it's in the end
It's still a little bit of guesswork
but I think
It's worth it
uh at the stage of my career for to
for me to
Do my best to do diligence and worst case and this i'm not afraid to do this
Let's say I take a job. It looks perfect. I do all my homework. I take it
I'll give it six months
There's the first 90 days of ramping stuff up if I find out in six months that you know
This company does not want me to do what they told me they wanted me to do. I'll just leave
Yeah
I don't I don't I don't i'm
I'll go through this whole looking for a job thing again
I am not going to again go back to zen spy don't want to lose my zen
I am not going to stick myself in a situation ever again where
I am
Doing work that I my full job is to do work. That was not what I was hired to do. Yeah
That's the worst method happens
To the best of us
Yeah, so but it's a good question something I think about a lot
Because I I also think about this on what matters to me in the job and I think the worst workplaces for me were
When they said that there is a certain value and then they would keep repeating it
But then I had felt this weird feeling in my body because the more I was in that company the more I realized
It was not being lived
So there was just this like greenwashing kind of situation right or value theater. Oh, yeah. All right
I wrote a sub stack
Yeah, i'm gonna ask for examples they have like yeah i'll probably my typical uh, because I interview companies
They interviewed me. I would ask you know, I would at this point if I get that far
I would look I would look at their values. They
I would first ask how how much does your company live these do they come up in meetings?
They'll say yeah and a lot say can you give me some examples they'll give me an idea and then i'll do my work
But you sort of have to have this bs radar, right?
You have to understand if they're actually truthful or not because yeah the more experience you are the the better
You are I guess at guessing this yet if you're gonna fairly early on
I think I was really bad at this. I would just buy it
Right. Well here and and I know more now, but here's what drives me crazy. Um,
Uh, I probably shouldn't use crazy. That's all here's what really frustrates me
Is that it isn't that hard?
To take care of people
Yeah
If you look at the gallup research over years people want to know their manager cares about them
They want to know why the job's important and they want feedback and manager meaning like manager cares about my career
They want feedback and they want to know why the job's important
I feel like every manager should be able to talk to their employees about that, but they don't
Would you say this is because we're sort of in in software development
We're so into experts on the or the individual contributors that we end up putting
Like very senior developer into a manager role and we don't appreciate the manager role for
What it is and then there's lots of people who have no idea what to do
And that's another big part of the problem why this occurs is we put these great engineers into management roles
Managing people is a completely different job than writing software
The expertise helps to make decisions, but we don't give them
Enough training and maybe another question last is what what manager training is available?
How do you like I do stuff in my organization? I have people do um, you know
A trial role in management or a temporary role to kind of sit and see what it's like
I'll give them the full responsibility without the reports
Uh, but what sort of management training is there?
How do you make sure people actually can make that transition because you're absolutely right so many people this this is true across all knowledge work, whether it's
Like I'll even say an accountant attack a
tax advisor an attorney
You move someone to a management role because they're really good at what they did before
But it doesn't help them. It's a whole new job. You hope they're smart and they'll figure it out
But you have to give them training and guidance and coaching. It's a very difficult. It's a it's a different job
Exactly. Yeah, and I think yeah that as you mentioned juniors empathy. It's so common. Oh my goodness
Okay, i'm a manager, right? So I will not tell you like what you actually did
But i'll just you know wrap it up because I want to be nice to you
It's oh everywhere. Well one thing and I want to get I want to talk a little bit about ai
because it wouldn't be an ab testing podcast if we didn't but
uh
One thing i've noticed a lot of companies companies do like some sort of engagement survey every year to check on engagement
and
I have seen teams
So and and not only is the manager excited but they get rewarded because
Almost their whole team says they're great
You know, it may be everyone like oh my god. I've never seen such a high
Engagement and what that tells me is I don't have to look
Every time i've looked at a team with matt with substantially higher engagement number
They're not delivering. Yeah
Their manager has worked very hard to make the team happy but has not held them accountable. They're living in ruinous empathy
I think on an engagement survey a perfect survey
Is you know 80% or higher think it's not there's nobody people aren't in the middle 80% or higher think you're awesome
And there's 10 to maybe 10 there's always some people in the middle
There's a there's a significant number of people 10% that think you suck
And that comes back to my favorite quote from leadership on the line leadership is disappointing people at a level they can absorb
And if you are challenging your team to grow
And and i've seen this you're gonna have a bunch of people say yeah, this is awesome
Some people I want to do it the way i've always done it. This is making me mad
And that yes, that's what you want. You want some differentiation. That's how I can tell that i'm giving people
Feed that's not just ruinous empathy. It's actually radical candor people are getting the feedback they need to grow
Whether they're good and getting better whether they're not performing and need to get their act figured out
And those people probably are angry in their engagement survey and that's fine. That's okay. Yeah, I want that
I want to I want to see some differentiation as they say life truth will set you free
But first it will piss you off. Um, so it will actually I don't know if you have to censor this out
But I think after reading radical candor, I don't censor. Sorry. We're stuck with that
After reading radical candor
I also realized that maybe I was falling into ruinous empathy and that I also hated leaders if I ever had managers who were
In ruinous empathy because I would rather someone tell me where I can improve because it's in a say in in a way care
If a person tells me then and then and you know, of course
It's an art. How do you say it in a nice way that it's also not as aggressive or rude
But I realized that you know, i'm i'm i'm not a good lead
If i'm not challenging people or telling them where they could improve that it's a part of my job
As you know
Inconvenient this is and it's annoying very frequently and if you're joining also as a lead and you inherit the team that frequently happens
They're comfortable and then you just show up and then you're like, hey this you should do better and it's like, oh
Well, I talk a lot about with my manager training about normalizing feedback like people should be used to feedback like
Lena, let me give you some feedback. It's like fight or flight. Nah
Yeah, you shouldn't be like oh, it's oh no i'm getting fired
No, because a lot of times it can be positive. I can use this sbi model situation behavior impact
I can even say
Lena there
Last week or this morning you sent some reports on metrics
They're all really actionable. A lot of people on the team gave me that feedback
How'd you come up with those so give you a chance to talk about them you get you gotten some positive feedback
I can and maybe maybe tomorrow it's
And these aren't like let me give you some feedback things. It's little things. It can be a slack message even
um a situation like lena
I liked in the in the meeting this morning. I liked how you brought some of the quiet people into the conversation
That was a great job on active listening. Thank you
redoing that consciously
So i'm not talking a lot. I'm giving you a chance to give me your feedback said
Oh, yeah, I like I like making sure everybody's voice is heard. So that's great. We'll keep on doing that
Then if you get used to feedback then when I say
lena
In the meeting i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do the bullshit sandwich. I can say lena in the meeting. We just came out of
a couple times you cut off
Fred when he was talking what was going on there?
You might say I was excited or I don't like fred, but you get a chance to talk about it
I said, well, what can we do and we talk about a corrective step. What can we do next?
So well, i'll take a minute before I respond even when i'm excited
Whatever can happen there, but it but
I want to normalize feedback because I want to give you lots of feedback all the time
It's not feedback is not a thing people get once a year at their performance review
Which many companies do and it's the stupidest thing in the world and they wonder why they're failing
I'm on a soapbox now
But just normalize feedback give people feedback all the time both positive and negative and it will work out great
And I think also now thinking about this ruinous empathy. I think ruinous empathy is a way to rig the people metric
Right, that's that's managers playing the game with that kind of metric, right?
Especially if there's a survey telling if i'm liked or not and you're a human in the end
You do want to be liked but then in this job and role of a lead. It's it's not just
butterflies
You should not be in management if you want everyone to like you all the time
It's just not it's you're not going to be good at it. Yeah
And i've known managers like this they get they want everyone to like them all the time
And that's nice, but you're not helping your team grow. You're not helping your team deliver. Yeah
Challenge them. Yes. So do you think ai could be a good manager?
Great transition
No, um, however, I do believe is reveal
My god linkedin people two years after two and a half years after maybe three years now since chat
You came out. I can't remember time flies. They still don't understand how gen ai works and it just i'm not even agreeing with that
I think ai gen ai is what we have now gen ai is a great companion
It can accelerate
uh people in any role whether you're
a leadership
whether you're uh
um
An ic you're getting getting code ideas
Um, it's a great collaborator
I don't know people are one people are freaked out saying oh ai is going to take my job
No, it's not people who know how to use ai effectively certainly are because you have your head stuck in the stand and you're an idiot
But i'll shut up and what what are your thoughts? What's like? Where do you see?
ai helping up and and how are people at first I was really
Annoyed with all the buzz about ai because I think five or seven years ago many years ago
I tested the chat bot and it was a machine learning chat bot and that was before ai was cool
and then my conclusion there was that
You know, we have to understand human communication first because that chat bot basically will talk as one of the developers in the team
Because that's how that was our data sample
And it led me to these thoughts about of course open source data sets that you know, we would base those
Chat bots on and so on and then when ai showed up there were so many talks that would be like
Oh ai will take over the world or these doom talks, right?
so much of
Catastrophizing and so much of talk without like
Like not not telling anything and also in testing conferences. I was like, oh Jesus. I mean seriously talking about this
um yet later on I think with time I also found like really useful things with ai
That there was this one
Automation at aqa actually that I met recently who was like, you know, I haven't written code for three months because there's you know
AI can write it much better and I just like review it and I use it and i'm much faster
But what he ended up working on was actually team processes and actually trying to automate
Things and see look at the system better improve code quality and so on
But he's just using it as a tool which for me was fascinating and I think overall
The more i'm thinking about all this i'm not terrified of losing my job at all
Because I was working on this like intangible part most most of the time I was working with people
And if you are working with systems overall, and if you are working with people
You know that it's not the code problem and the faster this moves right the faster
We can write code the faster we may also
Jump off the cliff
In the end because if we are not thinking about the systems or like what actually creates quality if we don't have good basic
Principles and habits it will backfire quite a lot. So I think I find my
Job fairly secure. I'm not scared of ai at all
I do find it useful at times to just speed up something
But I I had no idea how to do this or that and i'm like, okay, just help me out
I even tell my qas as well. Just you know go and figure it out
So it's not that nowadays, you know
You need some kind of mentor or like a special course to do something you can learn quite a lot
But overall for me, it's it's it's always a it's it's people problem
It still is I think a people problem it always will be
I don't know how we get around that because this
Maybe the ai gets so smart. We're we just sit
uh, just sit in our chairs, but I would also question like the
overall how
the data set of the models we use or like the
How international they are?
Because we are sort of what are we making a very generic world that you know is going to look very similar
Because recently even at work someone was discussing
Oh, yeah
This one country wants to generate a website because I actually work with open source and different countries right now
And they said oh yes, this country wants to generate a website
But it looks like every other website generated by ai
And there was this colleague of ours who really knows ai models and actually gave good tips how to make it
Stand out, but I think yeah, like how can we make sure that the world is more authentic that it is more diverse?
And we don't swallow it because in a sense even even this um
And come to think of it recently. I saw this one of the companies that we get to work with
They created a tutorial about something they built and there was this
Generated voice and it was with american accent and they are I think from nigeria
And it sort of made us sad, you know because we were like
Why and they're like, yeah, but we look more professional than
So in a sense, this is also are we then trying to get to the standard that because we can right?
But then we lose a bit of authenticity. So for me, that's a very interesting topic
I think that you know, how is it going to turn out and how do we not lose it?
How do we not feel less lesser somehow just because you know, I can generate something and I can have you know, american accent
And then it's this
World that centers certain experiences more than others
Yeah, it reminds me of something. I heard someone say a while back is for the really large models like chat gpt uses
It which is everything
It uses a model of literally everything
Ai really stands for the average of the internet. Yeah
Because it everything is generified. I think the real value in ai
I think chat gpt was the toy that allowed us to learn
A little bit and there's lots of value in there. It's a collaborator and it knows all the pieces
But
the more targeted models
or some of the agentic some of the agentic ai teams are building around specific like
product things
That's where some of the real wins are going to come from like when if you go back a couple years when brent and I
first started talking about
chat gpt and gen ai
I said two things one is the shift in skill is going to come from code writing to code reading
Yeah, it's more than reviewing. It's really digging in and fixing like this
It's doing what I wanted and you have to know this you cannot just
Right, right. You can't just copy and paste go you have to like take time to yeah
And the other one is like this is all fun
And i'm i'm one little dig here
The number of people still testing chat think saying they're testing chat gpt like as a
Deterministic model just is just driving markers. But anyway, uh
Is that the real chat gpt is a nice toy
It's very helpful
But the real win is going to come from the things people build on top of the not chat gpt
But the ai technology and we're beginning to see that
uh
Talking to a few different companies one thing in my mini retirement here. I'm getting invited to a good good chunk of
Small company advisory boards people I just know or know of people and they're all doing interesting things with uh,
Smaller still large but smaller models
To solve real customer problems and I think it's really cool people are beginning to innovate finally on top of the gen ai platforms
And that's actually exciting. They're actually solving real cost doing things that used to be really hard. Yeah making them easy
I talked about debugging kernel driver failures. I debugged so many of them like
who would have
You know
If we would have had gen ai 20 years ago. I was doing that at microsoft or whatever that was
There I wasn't the only one doing it. There was a bunch of us debugging all day blah blah blah blah
We would have should record those sessions train a model on them and have a model automatically debug these things for us
And that's what i'm thinking right now as well like we for example triage bugs and the project i'm in
And I was like, why don't we have something that would triage bugs for us because this is tedious
Like why don't we free up our time for something more creative, right?
But but that's the catch right that that's where it can help because you're not replacing the job per se you're just
Using the human creativity the innovation right learning how to innovate on top of that
That will be the power we are far too intelligent of creatures to waste our time on the domain
Yeah, so and I think hopefully over time people begin to see that with with
Maybe we'll find a new name for other than ai
It's almost like agile. It's become one of those terms
It's been bastardized so much it doesn't even mean the thing it used to mean
Even though it never meant the thing it was intended to mean in the first place
uh
Because gen ai isn't ai it's ish
so anyway, uh
Yeah, I think that is a great use for these tools. Let's let's
but
We can I feel like the same thing happens over and over
Automation is going to take your job away. Yeah. Yeah, right
Did it ever no because other stuff to do and and then we figured out later the devs should write the automation anyway
Now because the devs are writing a automation, uh, maybe we don't need testers. Yeah, we still need some testers
Uh, we need people to help the team understand how to do better testing and some products it makes sense to have people
Working alongside the developers testing not testing as a gatekeeper at the end
But automation didn't take your job away
It made your job change ai didn't take your job away, but it may make your job change exactly
Yeah
All right
Did we miss anything exciting in our in our chat this morning anything you wanted to bring up because I
Talked too much and took away all your time. Oh good. No, I don't think so
Is it anything? All right any uh, oh, uh, so you're working on a book and
Uh any how if someone wanted to for example
Keep track of when this book may come out. How would they do that? Uh, so it's going to be released on manning
Uh likely we will have early access release. I will post about everything on linkedin likely so you can find me on linkedin
And so i'll try remember put your linkedin profile in the show notes. That's a try
Uh, and lena it has been fantastic having you here as always so thanks for coming back
I always welcome back anytime come back next week. It's my first time. Hey
It's my first time here. You were in my podcast
Oh, I was in your podcast. I thought you were on our podcast. I was on your pod. I knew we talked
I knew yeah, and I was supposed to come on your podcast after my podcast but then life happened and then um, yeah
Oh
Well, this is my this is my hiker brain leaving me. So yeah first time on ab testing
So i'm sorry. I got that wrong, but welcome and you're also welcome back
Thank you so much great, all right great having you here, uh, I am
Not brent not alan. I'm spy
Lena, thanks for being here. Thank you spy